mon petit bureau c'est mon petit
vaisseau spatial ainsi à toronto
qui peut se vanter d'avoir son visage
sur une bouteille de ketchup offerte par
times
j'ai une poupée russe avec ses deux
membres d'équipage
c'est moi qui ai l'adulte à une fusée
jouets offerte par son fils un fils qui
donne des fusées à son père un
astronaute à la retraite
chris hadfield a une carrière
d'astronaute remarquée et remarquable
quand il a chanté du bouïs il en était à
son troisième séjour dans l'espace six
mois à bord de la station spatiale
internationale à vivre dans l'espace
avec comme paysage la planète terre
[Musique]
cette perspective cette compréhension de
nos terres ça reste à moi toujours
maintenant et c'est différent et pour
david j'imagine que ce serait exactement
la même chose
david saint jacques il le connaît bien
ils se côtoient depuis que c'est jacques
a été nommé astronautes
en 2009 ils étaient ensemble par exemple
au départ de fusées soyouz où chris
hadfield avait agi comme remplaçant
désigné au cas où l'astronaute
américaine sunnite à williams aurait été
forcé d'abandonner la mission
tous deux savent ce qu'il faut vraiment
craindre d'une expédition dans l'espace
du voyage le plus dangereux
absolument c'est le décollage de
lancement c'est parce que les grands
fusée avec l'accélération la force
seuls les normes étaient de ça on
utilise le carburant tellement vite le
plat mais tout ça c'est dangereux de
piloter contre l'atmosphère ça c'est le
neuf minutes dangereux
ces neuf minutes passent et les voici
dans l'espace
ensuite on se concentre sur l'arrimage à
la station spatiale internationale
le saas qui s'ouvrent les collègues qui
vous accueille et s'offre alors un des
beaux cadeaux de l' aventure la
découverte de la vie en apesanteur et
vous êtes dans la présente à ce site
bizarre c'est la première fois pour
david d'avoir cette expérience vous
pouvez voler voler dans l'air comme
suprême david saint jacques comme chris
hadfield avant lui restera six mois à
bord de la station spatiale
internationale
et comme chris hadfield il a une
conjointe et trois enfants
pourtant il n'aura pas le temps de
souffrir d'ennui vous êtes occupé tout
le temps et il y a
un horaire pour vous de chaque cinq
minutes pour david saint jacques
chaque cinq minutes est spécifié pendant
six mois qu'est ce que je fais
maintenant que surpris après cinq
minutes
il ya une ligne rouge qui marche sur
l'écran d'ordinateur qui dira c'est
david à gauche et david qu'est ce que
vous faites maintenant après cinq
minutes près zone à chaque jour pendant
six mois occupé comme une petite souris
blanches dans ça vous l'astronaute
cherche à s'échapper
si vous pouvez trouver cinq minutes
libre peut-être des milliers si vous
faites quelque chose plus vite que
planifié vous avez dix minutes gratuites
comme comme un petit cadeau et c'est
possible j'ai cinq minutes je peux
envoyer un email à ma femme où je peux
prendre quelques photos je peux faire
des petites expériences personnelles
dans la présente dans six mois ce sera
terminé david saint-jacques devra
revenir sur terre si la furieuse
ascension avait pris 9 minutes
la rentrée dans l'atmosphère sera moins
brutal et prendra une heure élevé mais
beaucoup moins que que le lancement quel
dès que le décollage
y aura-t-il d'autres astronautes
canadiens dans l'espace dans dix ans
dans 20 ans peut-être pas le prochain
défi c'est objectif lune le gouvernement
trudeau ne s'est toujours pas engagé à
participer au projet de construction
d'une nouvelle station spatiale autour
de la lune avec une base permanente sur
la lune
ottawa d'un passé s'est beaucoup fait
tirer l'oreille pour participer au
programme spatial c'était la même
problème mais nous avons pris la bonne
décision en ce temps là et je suis
confiant que nous allons faire la même
chose cette fois la lune ce n'est pas
pour lui chris hadfield est à la
retraite il donne des cours des
conférences a écrit un livre sur ses
expériences traduit en 25 langues ça
c'est je ne sais pas trop
j'ai hâte de parler avec ta vie après le
voyage et de encore peut-être voir cette
expérience de notre désir
théo tiennent à travers ses yeux verts à
travers des yeux de et s'échanger des
souvenirs car ils sont nombreux les
souvenirs quand on a mené une vie
d'astronautes est très belle et sa
guitare jusque dans l'espace
[Musique]